Little Prince Lou carus must have wet
himself when he entered Storm's end and
found King aegon's younger brother
Eamonn already with Lord Baratheon
Eamonn was fearsome even before he lost
his eye and set a sapphire in its stead
but the princeling pleaded his mother's
case finally Lord Baratheon made his
decision go on pup and tell the [ __ ]
your mother that the Lord of Storm's end
is not a dog she can whistle up as
eamonn's false eye gleaned at him the
princeling fled the castle and mounted
his young dragon arax the rain fell in
sheets and great bolts of lightning lit
the world bright as day
arax was struggling to stay aloft in the
Gale when a raw shook the very
foundations of Storm's end
Eamonn Rose through the clouds and Below
him the Monstrous Vega Vega was five
times the size of arax and the hardened
Survivor of a hundred battles
Vega culture map of [ __ ] breaker Bay
watches on the castle walls saw distant
blasts of flame and heard a shriek drown
out the Thunder
Prince Lucas fell broken to be swallowed
by the waves
with his death the war of ravens came to
an end
and the war of Fire and Blood began
for free you can now listen to the
entire audiobook Fire and Blood On which
house of the Dragon is based and which
covers the entire Targaryen history
including current and future events of
House of the Dragon for free with a
notable trial using our Link in the
description
foreign